(upbeat music)
(laughs)
- [All] Dunk the Vote
- This November,
you gotta get out and vote.
- It's all about democracy, y'all.
Your vote gets counted
with the rest of the votes in the country
and they get sent off to
the electoral college.
- What's that?
- The electoral college
are a bunch of officials
who do the voting for us.
So in case we elect the wrong person,
they can fix that shiz.
- Whoa, whoa, whoa.
Hold up.
Who the hell are these people?
- Well, no one knows for sure.
But whoever they is,
they the folks who
actually do the real voting
after we do our pretend vote.
Yeah.
- Power to the pe--
- Hold the (bleep) on.
You're telling me our votes don't matter?
- Our votes are like suggestions.
- So this November we should?
- Yeah.
- [All] Dunk the Vote.
(patriotic music)
- Good evening, my fellow Americans.
Now, before I begin,
I just want to say that I
know a lot of people out there
seem to think that I don't get angry.
Well, that's just not true.
I get angry a lot.
It's just that they way I express passion
is different from most.
So, just so there's no more confusion,
we've hired Luther here
to be my anger translator.
Luther.
- Hi.
- First off,
concerning the recent developments
in the Middle Eastern region,
I just want to reiterate
our unflinching support
for all people and their
right to a democratic process.
- Hey, all y'all dictators out there,
keep messing around and see what happens.
Just see what happens.
Watch.
- Also,
to the governments of
Iran and North Korea,
we once again urge you to discontinue
your uranium enrichment program.
- Hey, Mac Moo, Kim Jung,
I think I already done told both y'all,
86 your (bleep) bitches,
or I'm gonna come over
there and do it for y'all.
Please test me
and see what happens.
- On the domestic front,
I just want to say to my critics,
I hear your voices and I'm
aware of your concerns.
- So maybe if you can chill
the hell out for like a second,
then maybe I can focus on some (bleep).
- That goes for everybody,
including members of the Tea Party.
- Oh, don't even get me started
on these mother (bleep) right here.
- I want to assure you
that we will be looking
for new compromises with the GOP
in the months ahead.
- And you know these
mother (bleep) gonna say no
before I even suggest some (bleep).
- Now, I know a lot of folks say
that I haven't done a good job
at communicating my
accomplishments to the public.
- Because y'all (bleep) don't listen.
- Since being in office,
we've created 3 million new jobs.
- 3 million new jobs.
- We ended the war in Iraq.
- Ended the war, y'all.
We ended a war.
Remember that?
- These achievements
should serve as a reminder
that I am on your side.
- I am not a Muslim.
- And that my intentions as your president
are coming from the right place.
- They coming from Hawaii,
which is where I'm from,
which is in the United
States of America, y'all.
Okay?
This is ridiculous.
I have a birth certificate.
I have a hot, diggity doggity,
Mama Say Mama Sa Mama
Coosa birth certificate,
ya dumb ass crackers.
- Okay.
Luther.
Rope it in.
- Dial it back, Luther, damn.
- In conclusion,
last night I had a
conversation with Michelle--
- I says bitch.
- Nope, I did not say that.
I did not say that.
- When I roll down the street,
brothers all take a knee.
Honey's dropping they G's
wanting pieces of me.
'Cause I run this whole block
with these rhymes and this Glock,
make this whole damn hood tick,
this my town, I'm the talk,
cock of the walk.
I'm the boss and the king,
(bleep) kissing my ass and
bitches kissing my ring.
What's up, yeah.
Oh (bleep).
You know it's true.
- Yeah.
(laughter)
- I'm the leader of the free world.
(mic screeches)
(excited yelling)
- He's the president.
Forget y'all.
(soft jazz music)
(sighs)
- Here is your white wine.
- Thank you.
- You are welcome.
Hey, Pete.
Little thirsty tonight?
- Yeah.
Super thirsty.
- Pete, this is Horasa.
Horasa, this is Pete.
Horasa just got back from Africa.
- Oh.
Africa.
- Anyways,
where was I?
- Oh, the AUC.
- Oh, right.
So this conflict is exactly the reason
the African Union Commission
was put in place to address.
- [Horasa] The Organization
of African Unity
certainly wasn't going to do anything.
- Oh, exactly.
And if Nkosazana Dlamini-Zuma
wants to do anything about Bongwe,
she's certainly being quiet about it.
- The worst part about Bongwe
is that no one knows what's going on.
Look at right next door,
the South Sudan.
- Here's the thing,
everybody just thinks
it's the damn Lion King over there.
- Lion King.
- Excuse me?
- It's not The Lion King.
- Exactly.
- I mean, what do people think?
A baboon is gonna hold a lion cub
over a rock up to the sun
while all the little animals sing?
- Anyway,
something else I also wanted to mention
is they have the manpower,
because AMISOM has 2,500 troops
just sitting there in Somalia.
- It's not a three
animated hyena situation.
That doesn't make any sense.
The bad guy isn't Scar
over there.
- Um, yeah.
Yeah, that's right.
It's not like Scar's the bad guy.
- Well, the truth is,
no one knows who to blame.
Because in reality,
AMISOM doesn't have that much control.
- They don't.
- Like Simba.
Oh, like Simba.
He had no control over,
he was plucked out from his home,
and went on a whole journey
before he came back and was
just in the middle of a war,
really had nothing to do with him.
- You know, Pete,
I'd be really interested
in hearing your thoughts
on the UN's policies in East Africa.
- Hakuna matata.
- Unbelievable.
- Yes.
My god, that sums it up perfectly.
There's so much work still to be done.
- Yes, that's what I was saying.
- [Horasa] It's been going
on for so many years.
- So many years.
Circle of life.
- Hmm.
Exactly.
That's really brilliant.
- I don't know about brilliant.
Let's dial it back.
I'm just a man.
- Okay, I'm gonna...
I'm gonna go get some...
(clears throat)
Some hors d'oeuvres.
- Okay, no need to announce it.
- What are your thoughts
on the Middle East?
- Aladdin.
- Huh.
- Wasn't that the turn
for our polling station?
- Why no, young man.
See, we know a shorter route
to your...
To our Democratic polling station.
- You know how us
Democrats like a shortcut.
Like government spending
to prop up the economy.
- Nothing more we love then
those federal programs.
- You two are Democrats, aren't you?
- What?
(laughter)
- Of course, we are.
- You see the color of
our skin, don't you?
How could we not
blindly vote Democratic?
- I mean, that would be ridiculous.
- Whatever.
All I know is my polling
place closes in 15 minutes.
- Why, that would be terrible.
- Awful.
How are you going to elect
tax and spend politicians
if you can't vote?
- It's hard enough to vote
with all those voter I.D. laws.
Republicans.
(groans)
- Those gosh darn Republicans.
- I know, I'm just like (growls).
- 10 and two, Douglas.
If there were any Republicans here,
whoa ho ho ho.
I'd be pissed.
I mean, royally pissed.
- Me too, me too.
- In fact,
I'd take their hard fought principles
and I'd shove it right up their keisters.
- Oh, Arthur.
- We seem to be driving in circles.
- Don't worry, we're almost there.
(brakes screech)
Look.
It appears we've hit somebody.
We should get out and help him.
Heave ho.
- Aw, my leg.
Oh, my leg.
- Whoopsy daisy.
- I am pissed.
I'm royally pissed.
Now, although it was only
this one man's fault,
I will be using all of your
tax dollars to get healthy
thanks to the Affordable Healthcare Act.
I know it doesn't seem fair,
but that's supposedly the
law of the land nowadays.
- That's what I've heard.
- You don't look that hurt.
- Why y'all wearing those
same leather jackets?
And those dad jeans?
- Disperse.
(panting)
(gasps)
- Black Republican mother (bleep).
(patriotic music)
- Good evening, my fellow Americans.
Now, before we begin,
I'd like to once again
introduce you to my
anger translator, Luther.
- Hi.
- Now this November,
I want each and every one of you
to ask yourselves what has changed
in the last four years.
- Who killed Osama Bin Laden?
- What has my administration accomplished?
- Did we accomplish killing
America's biggest enemy?
Uh, check, did that.
Boom.
- In 2011 alone,
we created more jobs than George W. Bush
did in all eight years of his office.
- Except for Osama Bin Laden hunter,
because that job don't exist anymore,
because I went over there
and I killed him in his face.
- We helped make healthcare accessible
to more Americans than ever before.
- I'm sorry, what'd you say?
Your World Trade Center hurts?
Then why don't you take
two dead Bin Ladens
and call me in the morning, bitch?
- This election,
make the decision that
you think best serves
the future of this country.
- Or you could eat a dumb dumb sandwich,
and just vote for the person
who didn't kill Osama Bin Laden.
But why would you do it?
Why would you do it?
I'll be goddamn.
- I plan to run a clean campaign,
one based on the issues
and the accomplishments
of my administration.
- Ima tell you right now,
if the Republicans,
if they had caught Osama Bin Laden,
there wouldn't even be an election, man.
They just put a crown on his head,
and give him a castle,
and just call him the King of America,
and that'll be it.
I said that'll be it.
- All right, all right.
Just bring it down a notch there, Luther.
- Okay, come on, Luther, man.
You're straight up out
of control, brother.
- Well, it's not that bad.
- Okay, don't beat yourself up.
It's okay.
(coughs)
- Excuse me.
- Can a (bleep) get a lozenge?
- [Obama] Now, Luther.
You can't say that word.
- Actually, it says right here
I can say it whenever I want.
- I guess I can say it, too.
- Goodnight,
my (bleep).
(patriotic music)
- [Speaker] Hello.
And welcome to the fifth annual meeting
of the Tallahassee Black Republicans.
Now, I'm pissed.
Royally pissed.
Last November,
Barack Obama was reelected president.
And the black vote went
almost entirely to him.
We're not getting our message out.
Obviously.
The Republican party is and should be
the only home for black voters.
Now people think
that black voters are a monolith.
We're not a monolith.
- [Speaker] What?
- [Speaker] We're not.
- In fact, black Republicans alone
are an extremely diverse group of people.
(audience agreeing)
Now to speak more on diversity,
I present tonight's speaker,
Mr. Douglas Jackson.
(applause)
- Now I'm not going to
sugarcoat it, I'm pissed.
I am royally pissed.
The liberal media thinks
that Republicanism
is not for black people.
Now you tell me what about
fiscal responsibility,
a strong national defense,
and limited government
is unappealing to black people.
We're not a monolith.
We come in all different shapes and sizes.
- Yes, we do.
- Now who here would like
to come up to this podium
and speak about the diversity
amongst black Republicans?
(clears throat)
- Gentlemen, we have a real treat today.
A gentleman who is a little bit eccentric,
a little bit outside
of the box if you will.
- But I can't think of
a better person to speak
on diversity amongst black Republicans
than this gentleman right here.
All the way from Orlando,
my good friend Arthur Washington,
ladies and gentlemen.
(applause)
Thank you, sir.
- Thank you for the
introduction, brother Douglas.
- Thank you for being here,
brother Arthur.
- However, I am pissed.
Royally pissed.
- Indeed indeed.
- Democrats think they have a
right to all the black people.
But that is not the case.
We are not a monolith.
Democrats may be cool,
but they ain't practical.
- There you go.
- Republicans are practical.
Black people are practical.
Come to think of it
- Get those pants.
- I think black Republicans
are pretty cool.
- So do I.
- Not to mention very diverse.
- [Speaker] Excuse me, gentlemen.
Sorry to interrupt.
Someone's white wife is
here to pick them up.
(people chattering)
- [Douglas] Was her name Emily?
- Uh, she was white.
- Okay.
- Good evening, my fellow Americans.
Now as you know,
sometimes during the chaos
of a presidential campaign,
it's easy to forget the beauty
of the Democratic proce--
- This is it.
Armageddon!
Y'all got to vote for me, y'all.
You have to,
or you'll get bent over
by a bunch of bitch ass billionaires.
(siren sounds)
- This is my anger translator, Luther,
who I thought had the day off.
- What the (bleep) are
you doing here, Luther?
(window shatters)
- Anyway.
I think that everybody
needs to take a moment to appreciate
that our political system truly works.
- Unless Romney wins,
and then the (bleep) is broke.
- And despite the heated
rhetoric of a campaign,
there's always a place
for civil discourse.
- As long as you got a few
million dollars lying around
so you can counteract
all the negative ads.
Hey Romney and Karl Rove
and all you evil mother (bleep)
with your slimy ass super packs,
y'all done poked the hornet's nest
with a sugar stick.
Y'all slapped Frankenstein
right in the bolts, man.
(grunts)
And you know what, after I win this,
I'm taking all y'all down.
- Thank you,
and I'll see you all
on the campaign trail.
- And when you give me
your babies to kiss,
please clean they diapers, all right?
'Cause I ain't trying to kiss no poop.
Just wash they ass.
You know, just wash they ass.
- It's true.
You should wash they ass.
(patriotic music)
(upbeat music)